Jennifer how are you
um
10 years ago there's no way ten even
five years ago there's no way this role
would have gone to a woman what does it
mean to be a legitimate like you were an
action star we do beat a little little
ass in this movie we do
um listen I think it's an amazing thing
you're right like for a woman to have a
role like this but also for like I
expected to get roles like this or I
would have liked to get really this in
my 20s and 30s and now I'm doing it at
this point in my career to me is
for myself super empowering you know
what I mean and so it's it was it was a
great role and I think Nikki Caro who
directed it did a great job kind of
opening it up and making a big action
film and uh I was happy to kind of come
up to the task
the way you protect that child is to
disappear
and if I don't
like I'll find you
Lucy just told me a great story so it
was this really intense mentally and
physically intense scene I had to run
like 100 yards of really deep snow and
crying and then I went to this black
tent and there was this guy who kept
going on how amazing the scene was and I
was like I really thank you but I'm
trying to like calm down so give me a
moment and then I kind of because I
started seeing kind of blurry you know
and then I came back to life and I saw
that it was Ben Affleck next to me and
then we started speaking Spanish because
we're like Mexican besties did she say
yeah it was so funny yeah it's funny
they kind of hit it off they smoke in
Spanish and you know because she's from
Mexico and so uh yeah they had a good
time
and tell me this is I missed that story
I didn't know about that yeah yeah early
that happened also
um your mother was on a today show and
she said she had been waiting for years
hoping for years for you and Ben to get
back she never said that to me she knew
you'd always knew that you would always
get back together because I prayed for
20 years we never spoke about it no no
it was a baby she really loved him when
we were together before so maybe deep
down I don't know last last thing how
far have you gone to protect your own
dog has there ever been a time where you
have almost beat somebody's behind to
protect your own daughter I mean I
wouldn't mention it on TV but it's
happening
okay
[Music]